welcome to Blind Side hi guys came
across this really cool indie game
called blindside and it's very different
because it's a horror game but it makes
you feel as though you're blind
so there's no visuals whatsoever it's
all audio it sounds really creepy you
know not actually knowing what you're
scared of and just hearing it I don't
know much else about it I just know that
starting new game hmm
good morning what am i doing oh I'm
kidding
can't see a thing let me get the
flashlight batteries must be dead you
pick so weird I can't tell if I'm moving
I'm gonna get the matched in the kitchen
I'll be right back
store muster knocked out the power lines
press X now to skip the tutorial press
escape
the hell what's wrong um I'm not sure
let me I'm reaching the hallway Wilbert
damn damn damn
okay you partment doors just to my right
okay so I'm not setting my apartment and
someone crying should I go to listen
right here Cindy is that you okay
I hope so mad at you I think I'm blind
I won't go Anna I can't see anything can
you can you help me get to the hospital
dammit Don and I can't see either we
need to call 9-1-1
who's there Arnold okay what's that
noise
I'm coming hold on
ah wrong apartment I need to get back in
the apartment not close to the carnage
I'm sorry Thursday you have died coding
last saved I'm an idiot
Shh dawn I'm here okay yeah I'm here to
finding out the hallway it God's into
you I close my eyes what do we do while
we're blind
okay let's do it the windows in front of
me next to the bed okay Wow damn coffee
by the window
yeah you first
just go
I don't know why keep on looking the
screen there's like no point this is a
black screen greatly musical you okay
everything in one piece I think so
what was that I don't know need to get
help I brought my song you're awesome
you're awesome girl the number you have
reached has been disconnected
damn you're still awesome to get to a
landline so we can just yell for help
listen though I don't think anyone is
out here how do you know what time day
or night it is I guess if we get hit by
whatever's going down the street it will
kill us because it's apparently what
things are doing now ah but if we has a
landline anymore
there's one of my arms you're talking to
that person with the worst sense of
direction here okay
my approach all right try to cool a
minute
I know anything that only lasts saved
checkpoint is this fist because man them
you have died loading last life a
difficult you you have died I don't know
what I'm doing right now it's a simple
trick ha paucity okay I got somewhere
better nowhere
I don't wanna do it Hey not seeing you
have died ah have died
oh here we go here's a fountain
now we're assuming things on our right
fountain behind by Satan when you walk
to the Arts and Sciences
do you hear another monster nothing you
should keep going master okay
so they don't like water like inside
dawn what is it sorry
something stupid stupid let me check it
out
but aDNA all those campus police there's
not much left
zombies but I got his gun there's a gum
yes I have an environment when time
crisis serious case you're gonna hurt
yourself look I'll be careful I promise
if you had heard what it happened to
Cindy ID well let's just keep moving
okie dokie finally we're in progress
this is a long skinny hallway with
offices on the left and right we can
follow it down to the ballroom Lobby go
through there and get to my office in
the hallway on the other side well I
don't hear anything trying to kill us in
here there's still time
let's just find a landline okay let's go
hello sweetie and Navin me quiet Shh
don't move
oh I I don't think were you danger dawn
what did you hear
I did that wasn't one of those monsters
let's just get to your office okay
quietly what I don't understand okay god
I hate not seeing things
damn it the door to the lobby is locked
hey winged go to the ballroom it's there
another way around we can go through the
ball in itself the ball on door should
be on the left side of the hall towards
this end this way towards the music set
towards music music fine
here it is that's smell
my smelly socks doctors are doing it
what Shh listen
breathing this place smells like those
monsters oh I guess we'll have to go
through we should be able to just slide
along the back wall to my right and go
through the door on the far side how
many monsters are in here I don't know a
lot saving checkpoint huh what do you
think that the monsters look like to me
they look like Corps fellows you're like
oh no no that way yeah like Shh don't
back away slowly just look good
I don't think I will get up dear I'm
with a layout of this room so they're
gonna be clear towards the back wall I'm
pretty sure it's just a big empty room
except when they set up tables for
events let's head towards that steam
sound Cummings navigator and then over
the music coming through the Fargo yeah
I love the music as I was saying I see
them as Gruffalo's like really big with
sharp teeth in like brown fur but kind
of cute but obviously they kill you say
this is not home alright
I'm just following the steamy sound I
suck I suck I suck at being blind
they're all about me
go back this way towards music those
days good choice if it does so is it I
don't think so I reached it doors a lot
thank God
full Josh goodbye monsters I have no
idea they were safe for the time being
then move the active 200 horrible things
gonna happen to us next it's always
pretty much like the last one I think
I've just gone like where's your land
again I'm talking my book show which is
against the back wall directly behind my
desk do you want me to help look for it
no thanks I think I'm get the hang of
this ready I don't remember leaving my
wall stereo on hmm do without that no
leave it on what's that beeping noise oh
it is in the cave I thought like my fart
I was going off and I was like oh [ __ ]
I'm inside playing on games my auntie
drawing desk I missed you ah I'm just
talking to my desk that's gotta be
this really old Heather so like
optimistic and they're like yes spy we
just lost our eyesight which is gonna
get killed
so good okay where is my blood
phone is am I left somewhere ah thank
God what the phone's dead
something in circuit you probably jammed
what are we gonna do case I'm thinking
I'll tell you what you're going to do ah
geez well is that you I'm so glad to
hear you case dawn is that you I'll tell
you what you're going to do okay I guess
besides being blind unable to call for
help oh happy hour neighbor
torn to shreds in the hallway and
dealing with the end of the world like
thanks for asking professors scare us to
death
not so good can you see no I'm blind is
a bad I take it you are - yeah we're
asleep when it happened we came here
because there was something in the
hallway eat my bunny we had Sonny sir
more than senses well I was working late
Nona left my clock I heard thunder it's
all blue flash and then everything went
car accidents outside etc etc that was a
couple hours ago I've heard the
creatures talking in the hall since then
I take it that's what got your neighbor
yeah you know they are no I thought
maybe escaped zoo animals but they just
don't sound like anybody ever heard
before if you listen carefully they make
these sharp clicks
I hear one of the creatures get out of
the view of the door what okay
saving check Bob thank you presses voice
over here what are you waiting for
come in I think over here huh what are
you waiting for huh case
ah I suck at this that much it's like
how many times can you die died loading
last season oh you can't do this haha
God where is suck at being by last saved
checkpoint what are you waiting for
no don't move I brought what is it gone
we lost him their sense of smell is it's
terrible explains what they smell so bad
what are we going to do we're going to
baby deer a hatchery study it kill it
and then
what I'm kidding we're not gonna eat it
we are going to catch it you're insane
you actually sound like you're enjoying
this he is Alan might be a mild-mannered
biology professor during the day but he
lives for cryptozoology the last
sabbatical was spent at luck I just have
Lingam she's right though Alan you can't
let this one go think about it
something big has happened we all know
it those creatures are everywhere
there's just too many of us crazies
everywhere
ah it's a mean rule that's the dog open
my mouth public looking only other real
options just to be a total chicken for
the last time I am NOT chicken Alan bad
case I love you but this I can't
come on dog Oh Jonas supergirls it was
very things give us bad day you know
what screw it
you both are insane but it's not like I
have any other options
I'm in how much a monster excellent case
I told you she was a keeper
I'd hug you but I probably just poke you
in the eye Oh what's the plan to follow
me into the hall I'm gonna close my eyes
from now on hear that beeping way at the
end of the hall yeah that's the fire
alarm control thought I was afraid I was
going to go down there try to creature a
specimen you might say and then run
downfall in classroom 201 a which is
connected by doors to a would be one of
us will slam the first door after you
and the monster through the other one of
us will slam the other door between you
and the monster trapping the monster
201a uh did you say that when that I
absolutely would be big but my knee
hurts so your bed dawns unto a would be
your knee hats open you called me a
chicken I swear to God
if Keith gets hurt I will kill you he'll
be fine yeah promise I love you baby
follow me I'll walk you through the
escape pod dawn don't chase I'll see you
soon okay out yeah don't like offered to
do it for me or anything
kill you come on case I cleared out most
of the desks earlier wait you've been
planning this yeah anyways give me a
head we need to move the last two desks
al yeah why do you think we went blind
some settling do you think we'll get our
site back it could be awesome
- Drock side it turns black on contact
even very tiny amounts we have some in
the lab that is horrifying
I thought it might be a league but
between the car accidents and YouTube
going blind plus a big question of what
the how those monsters are I'm going to
guess that is that good maybe oxidation
by osmium tetroxide is even personal and
that level of exposure would probably
lead to pulmonary edema on the next few
hours my second guess is some sort of
radiation the blue flash coming this guy
just wants Cristo like he doesn't sound
like he should be this intelligent
mutation babbling on about scientific
now follow me on into the next classroom
I suck at this the classrooms and the
Arts and Sciences Building are pretty
much all the same there are two doors on
the wall that are shared with the
hallway and two windows in the opposite
wall I need to find a desk to move out
of classroom a the desk is in front of
me
we're building a mrs. death birth desk
that you speak off I need to find a desk
to move out of classroom at the desk is
to my right it's not though that's one
of the last two deaths
Oh desk is in front of the room am i
doing it right connecting the classrooms
now to drag this amazing desk out of
this classroom and make a pile of other
desks the objective is in front am I
going the right way all I hear was like
one down one to go hey Alice would be
ready now I've done this before I said
to drag this test into the other room
one of the others not only one step
closer to running for my life again on
purpose the objective is in front of me
okay you can't move through a copy in
front of you [ __ ]
sorry that's not nice right any closer
imbecile
okay oh can you go closing lots of two
doors in the classroom already then me
dawn and I back here I want to check the
escape path there are two doors that
lead to the hall on the south wall it'd
be such a shame to trap the Creech
they're just ahead a waltz out into the
hall and to have a flush of our bones
good such a shame
I hope you have the keys kind of sliding
on the south wall it's the one the chair
of the hallway okay got to close the
door one doors to my left the subway
last one connecting the classrooms great
both doors are locked
I should head back to Alan and on the
other classroom I just keep on pressing
H I'm such a cheater I can't play this
properly
I'm just suck at being blind how do
people do it I have high respect myself
what bathroom a radiator
oh gosh it's just too hard so weird it's
just really surreal playing a game
what's ball looking anything yeah no
it's really odd just heightened senses
where am I going
an overhead projector I need to head
towards Alan some sort of a plan and
probable death the doors behind us
done done I want you to start yelling
the case when you hear them in to the
far side of the room case just aim for
Dawn's voice okay fine on the right and
just head for God's voice when you get
in here it's a straight shot so you
should be fine if you just aim okay
follow me down the hall to the first
door we'll all be standing Don will stay
here at the second door okay now gate oh
come on just say it more help me out
here north wall uh-huh
you're just care like master vitomir you
like fine wool we know Ellen's in front
of me no he's not I'll be yelling for ya
go through here as you approach you'll
have to aim slightly left of my voice
because I'll be behind the door what if
the creature stops and eats you what's
with dog she's just upset on account of
this entire situation
Plus why she thinks you're a bad
influence on me why I have no idea huh
weird anyways got the plan I think I
know I paid a creature at the beeping
control panel run by you two done ready
when you are
hey you know he's a bad scare horse
pointing it's something and pull the
trigger you have one ah well it's about
your Casa decision goes do it in case
yeah I'll log soon thanks al this is the
other Bank what am i doing too late now
time to head to the fire alarm console
okay
oh my gosh I got a turn on and run as
soon as I pull this go
please go through here
this right here the doors right here dun
dun okay oh did it okay I'm sure me too
I'm also not dead more than I can say
for our friend here Jesus that was loud
wow this thing is all teeth and claws
Dexter's fingers teeth and QALYs thumbs
like human hands but four inch claws
that extend over them this is incredible
absolutely incredible quadrupedal in a
matter of speaking a Gruffalo what is it
it's alien it has to be there's nothing
like this on earth or there wasn't
before a few hours how do you know how
do we do they're in hiding let's listen
to music thank you for playing blindside
you completed episode 1 blindside is a
game developed by Aaron Rasmussen and
Michael T astrology
Michael Tia Stoll vias case Michelle
sciata as dawn
Paul Resnick off as power Andrea corn
students Cindy Thomas selfie is the
voice of the emergency broke too and
nothing stars like that was pretty cool
wasn't it and it wasn't as Horrors I'd
like it to be I would prefer to be like
totally crapping myself but I think we
put a bit too many jokes but at the same
time it was quite entertaining and it
was really different and that's what I
loved about it and that's why I needed
to show you guys so yeah I put a link in
the description so you can have a girl
true you're better than me because I'm
just suck at being blind do a thumbs up
if you liked it
have a lovely day or evening bye I'm
definitely gonna put the game down
because it starts and then suddenly
start doing well and you're like I'm
like a genius like now look at me oh my
god